des canons allemands haut des falaises
des plages le long de la côte en juin 44
a eu lieu le débarquement de normandie
bayeux a été libéré en une journée par
les troupes anglaises
les allemands ont fui la ville et ça a
permis d'éviter que bayeux soit détruite
par les bombardements alliés dans
l'ancien séminaire devenu musée dans la
pénombre pour la préserver une
tapisserie vieille de plus de 900 ans
qui fait 70 mètres de long
la tapisserie de bayeux raconte la
conquête de l'angleterre à partir de la
normandie par guillaume le conquérant
il faut s'imaginer être de nuit c'est la
traversée de la manche par un millier de
navires qui ont embarqué les hommes
l'armement on voit ici des boucliers
mais aussi les chevaux c'est la
cavalerie près de près de 500 chevaux de
500 à 700 chevaux qui sont qui sont
embarqués de nuit et qui au matin au
petit matin arrive sur la côte anglaise
ap vannes chez et on assiste ici au
débarquement la l'invasion commence
c'est à hastings aura lieu la bataille
pour le trône d'angleterre entre
guillaume duc de normandie et harold
droit anglo saxon est donc ici alors ici
nous sommes en plein coeur de la
bataille
on assiste à l'effondrement de la
cavalerie normande sur le monticule sur
lesquels s'est regroupé l'armée anglaise
la bataille dure 12 heures guillaume
l'emportent et devient roi d'angleterre
[Musique]
ont fait un bond dans le temps de 900 en
1953 elizabeth 2 et couronnée reine
d'angleterre
ça a lieu ou à l'abbaye de westminster
et qui a été le tout premier à être
couronné dans cette abbaye 25 décembre
1066 guillaume le conquérant elizabeth 2
et la lointaine descendante d'une lignée
qui remonte à guillaume et donc la
bataille d'hastings décrite sur la
tapisserie de bayeux
c'est un événement fondateur de
l'angleterre
les petits anglais la première date que
les petits anglais apprennent à l'école
c'est 1066
pour les français c'est 1789 la prise de
la bastille et pour les anglais c'est
1066 avec comme image de cette année de
cet événement majeur de 1066 la
tapisserie de bayeux qui est derrière
cette broderie de laine sur toile de lin
et pleine de mystères ou at elle été
confectionnés on n'est pas certain
peut-être en angleterre qui l'a conçu on
ne le sait pas qui l'a commandé
pas sûr peut-être le demi frère de
guillaume aux dons de bayeux ici les
anglais puis le champ de bataille
autre mystère est ce qu'il manque un
morceau à la fin de l'histoire s'arrête
à la déroute des anglais alors qu'elle
devrait se terminer à l'abbaye de
westminster c'est cette partie
probablement qui nous manque en fait
vous savez pas si vous mentez nous ne
savons pas si elle nous manque mais dans
l'histoire ne serait pas complète si
elle ne s'achevait pas par le
couronnement du duc de normandie roi
d'angleterre
on est certain d'une chose les anglais
la vénère et le président macron a
accepté que la tapisserie de bayeux
fasse son premier voyage à l'extérieur
de la france elle n'a jamais quitté le
sol français ont presque mille ans la
tapisserie sera exposée à londres dans
quatre à dix entre bayeux et
l'angleterre sont très très ils sont
très importants ils sont intimes on aime
à dire que mes yeux la plus anglaise des
villes françaises juin 44 des milliers
d'anglais sont morts pulvérisé par les
obus déchiquetés par les mitrailleuses
en normandie
c'est à bayeux où se trouve en france le
plus grand cimetière du commonwealth
britannique
il y à nos canadiens ici des jarries
chartrand desrosiers
l'immense majorité près de 4000 sont
anglais morts pour libérer la normandie
cette même normandie qui les avaient
conquis neuf cents ans plus tôt un
mémorial porte une inscription en latin
qui leur rappelle nous vaincu par
guillaume avons libéré la patrie du
vainqueur